hello everyone welcome to part two in
our series on presenting your research
we're going to be talking about writing
papers in our fields
to start let's look at the outline of a
typical nlp paper by and large these are
either four or eight page papers in a
two column format that you get from the
style sheets those lengths don't include
the references
and there are a bunch of conventions for
how the papers are typically organized
so you have your title and abstract on
page one and usually you have an intro
section that kind of fits on that first
page maybe a little bit onto the second
in place two you discuss the related
work or prior literature or background
that's needed to kind of contextualize
the work that you're doing
then there's typically a data section
followed by a section on a model or this
could be thought of as the kind of core
proposal section of the paper
then there'll be some methods related to
the experiments
a reporting of the results of the
experiments
and then some analysis of what the
experimental results mean and then
possibly a short conclusion
it's not set in stone that you have to
follow these conventions but if you do
follow them i think it will be easier on
your readers and also easier on you as a
writer because you can kind of slot your
ideas into this familiar format
let's look at those sections in a little
bit of uh of detail so starting with the
intro the ideal intro to my mind really
tells the full story of your paper at a
high level we don't need all the details
but it is very helpful to know from
beginning to end what the paper
accomplishes and good intros provide all
of that information and really tell the
reader precisely what they'll learn as
they go through the rest of the paper
in place two as i said is the discussion
of background material or related work
or prior literature this is an
opportunity for you to contextualize
your work and provide insights into the
major themes of the literature as a
whole what you should really be thinking
about doing is using each paper or each
theme that you identify as a chance to
kind of contextualize your ideas and
especially articulate what's special
about the contribution that you're
making so this kind of sets the stage
for the reader
the data section this could vary a lot
this could be very detailed if you're
offering a new data set or using a debia
set in some unfamiliar way the
community's not used to but of course if
you're just adopting some data off the
shelf then this section might be pretty
short
then you get to the heart of your
proposal your model you want to flesh
out your own approach and really help us
understand your core contribution
then we turn to supporting your ideas
with some experimental evidence you'll
report the methods your experimental
approach
including descriptions of the metrics
and again that will be long or short
depending on whether the metrics are
familiar or unfamiliar you want to
describe your baseline models and
anything else that's relevant to kind of
understanding precisely what's going to
happen in your experiments
i will say that for details about hyper
parameters and optimization choices and
so forth you can probably move those to
an appendix unless they're really
central to the argument what you want to
offer here are kind of the crucial
pieces that will help the reader
understand precisely what you did for
your experiments
then we get our results this could be a
no-nonsense report of what happened it's
probably mainly going to be supported by
figures and tables that report a summary
of your core findings according to your
data models and metrics
and then things open up a bit you have
an analysis section i think this is
really important you should articulate
for the reader what your results mean
what they don't mean where they can be
approved where their limits are and so
forth right these sections vary a lot
depending on the nature of the paper and
the findings but i think they're always
important and they can be very rewarding
it is intimidating because this is
awfully open-ended but i'm hoping that
the previous unit on analysis methods in
our field offer some really good general
purpose tools and techniques for doing
rich analyses of this sort and really
helping us understand precisely what you
accomplished
now
this is as i said is not set in stone
and different projects will call for
different variants on it and one really
prominent variant that you see is that
if you have multiple experiments with
multiple data sets you might want to
repeat that methods results analysis
rhythm across all of your experiments to
give them kind of separate sections in
your paper but again it really depends
on what you think the most natural way
to express your ideas is these things
aren't set in stone they're just
conventions that help us as readers and
as authors
then finally you have a conclusion this
is probably a quick summary of what the
paper did
and then an opportunity for you to chart
out future directions that you or others
might pursue so it's a chance to be more
outward looking and expansive
let me close the screencast with some
general advice on scientific writing
that i think can be helpful kind of in
the background as you think about
expressing your ideas
first i just want to review this really
nice piece from stuart shiber where he
advocates for what he calls the rational
reconstruction approach to scientific
writing and to build up to that he
offers two construct contrasting styles
that you might think about
the first is what he calls the
continental style this is in which one
states the solution with as little
introduction or motivation as possible
sometimes not even saying what the
problem was
he says readers will have no clue as to
whether you're right or not without
incredible efforts in close reading of
the paper but at least they'll think
you're a genius
at the other end of the extreme here you
have what he calls the historical style
and this is a whole history of false
starts wrong attempts near misses
redefinitions of the problem
this is a kind of genuine history of
maybe the struggles that you endured as
you built up to the final product for
your paper and shiber says this is much
better than the continental style
because the careful reader can probably
follow the line of reasoning that the
author went through and used this as
motivation but the reader will probably
think you're a bit addle-headed we don't
need to hear about every dead end and
every false start what we would like
rather is what sheba calls the rational
reconstruction you don't present the
actual history that you went through but
rather an idealized history that
perfectly motivates each step in the
solution you might selectively choose
models that you abandoned as a way of
helping the reader understand how you
built toward your actual core set of
methods and findings and results
so it's going to be a kind of
streamlined version of that historical
style
the goal in pursuing the rational
reconstruction style is not to convince
the reader that you're brilliant or at
all headed for that matter but that your
solution is trivial
shiber says it takes a certain strength
of character to take that as one's goal
right the goal
of writing a really excellent paper is
that the reader comes away thinking that
was clear and obvious that even i could
have done it that's an act of genuine
communication
and it does take a strength of character
but in the end this is what we should
all be striving for this kind of really
clear and open communication
this is also a nice document from david
goss who has some hints on mathematical
style there's a bunch of low-level
details in there especially related to
presenting very formal work the piece
that i wanted to pull out is just have
mercy on the reader this is again
recalling the rational reconstruction
approach that sheba advocated for where
you're really thinking about what it's
like to be a reader encountering the
ideas for the first time and genuinely
trying to understand what you
accomplished you have to really think
about what it's like to be in that
position in order to have a successful
and clear paper
i also really like this piece from the
novelist cormac mccarthy which he
published in nature it's full of great
advice the one piece that i wanted to
highlight is this mccarthy says decide
on your paper's theme and two or three
points you want every reader to remember
this theme and these points form the
central thread that runs through your
piece the words sentences paragraphs and
sections are the needlework that holds
it together if something isn't needed to
help the reader understand the main
theme omit it
this is helpful to me because i think it
not only results in a better paper but
it will also be easier for you to write
your paper because the themes you choose
will determine what to include and
exclude and resolve a lot of low-level
questions about your narrative
and conversely i've often found that
when i'm really struggling to write a
paper it's because i haven't figured out
what these core themes are and i'm kind
of casting about unsure of what's
relevant and what's irrelevant and if
you step back and really figure out what
you're trying to communicate then the
act of writing
kind of all falls into place
and then the final bit of advice that i
wanted to offer which i'm going to
return to when we when we talk about
presenting work at conferences this
comes from patrick blackburn it's about
talks but it really extends to any kind
of communication and science his
fundamental insight he asks
where do good talks and i think good
papers where do they come from and he
says
honesty
a good talk or a good paper should never
stray far from simple honest
communication and you can hear this in
the way that we talk about evaluating
your work that fundamentally for us
we're looking for papers that offer open
clear honest communication about what
happened and what it means and that's
like really a fundamental value and i
think it's inspiring to think about this
as your kind of guiding light when you
report your scientific results to the
community